Eccoci qua altro che discriminazione
quest'anno è un onore poter essere qui
su questo palco non come presentatrice
della manifestazione ma come speaker e
quando mi hanno chiesto se avrei voluto
rivestire questi panni ho subito chiesto
a stare Silvia che sono le mie due mie
amiche referenti se potessimo essere in
due Sara che è lì già al dovere mi ha
risposto sì purché la voce sia una sola
a parlare lui ancora non parla però
sicuramente ogni tanto farà mancare a me
un po' di voce mi darà un po' di
affaticamento ma ce la faremo Iniziamo
da qui Eccomi come diceva Paolo
nell'introduzione il mio sogno di
bambina non era sicuramente quello di
fare la giornalista Ma la nuotatrice
volevo essere una campionessa e ero sui
giornali non come firma in questo caso
va come protagonista una piccola
promessa del nuoto Che poi purtroppo non
ha realizzato il suo sogno che era
quello della Divina di Federica
Pellegrini diventare campionessa
olimpionica di nuoto non è stato
possibile ci siamo accontentati di
questi è risultati e di questi articoli
su un quotidiano per cui ancora oggi
collaboro Ecco cosa c'è in comune Però
fra la professione del nuotatore e
quella del giornalista soprattutto
quando il nuotatore è un mezzofondista
quindi fa distanzia abbastanza lunghe lo
dico sempre c'è la tenacia la tenacia
nel rimanere in acqua a nuotare la
tenacia nel rimanere all'interno di una
redazione di un emittente locale con
tutti i problemi che ci possono essere
rispetto a quelle nazionali e cercare di
andare avanti Ogni giorno per resistere
in un ambiente che non è facile perché
le crisi l'editoria Insomma lo sappiamo
tutti vive un momento difficile ma
andare avanti è faticoso ma allo stesso
tempo ti regala ogni giorno delle
bellissime emozioni
Questo è il primo articolo corredato
eravamo nel 2002 ero ancora
universitaria una stagista in una
redazione di tutti uomini e in un
periodo in cui la stagista per
eccellenza era lei e di fatto potete
immaginare quante battute in una
redazione di tutti uomini ed un'unica
donna Devo dire però che al di là di
tutto I miei colleghi mi hanno insegnato
veramente tanto e mi hanno fatto credere
in questo mestiere dicevamo Insomma
quello è stato il primo articolo sulla
carta stampata poi ho un po' virato
senza Mai abbandonare la carta stampata
per arrivare alla prima avventura
televisive in un'emittente locale che
oggi non esiste più ma che porto nel
cuore nella quale ho mosso i primi passi
Come dico sempre nessuno nasce imparato
anche per chi arriva oggi nella nostra
emittente che è quasi un network perché
Marchi Abruzzo Piemonte Insomma adesso
ci stiamo un po' allargando anche al
Lazio nessuno nasce imparato è andare in
video stare in onda stare davanti a una
telecamera stare su un palcoscenico lo
si impara Strada facendo bisogna
esercitarsi un po' Come andare in
gentilezza Allora vi faccio vedere come
ero io alle prime armi per farmi capire
che è davvero difficile
coreografie da sogno per i Carmina
Burana al porto di San Benedetto
al via estate in Appignano tra libri e
degustazioni
Buonasera e Ben ritrovati a questa
edizione del martedì di TVB notizie Come
avrete sentito dai titoli un incidente
sulla A14 a paralizzato questa mattina
Insomma sorvoliamo sul look sul parrucco
sul sull'abito Però all'epoca arrivarono
anche delle lamentele in redazione per
la mia conduzione
i titolari Allora mi dissero Stringi i
denti vai avanti Provaci e io feci così
da Allora diciamo che tante altre volte
sono andata in video credo di essere un
po' migliorata e negli anni grazie Un
po' l'età Grazie all'esperienza ho
rivestito per l'emittente per cui oggi
lavoro anche il ruolo di direttore
responsabile Ecco molti mi domandano Ma
perché non hai mai provato a fare il
salto verso l'emittenti locali
semplicemente nazionali Scusate
semplicemente perché di occasioni ne ha
avute solo due perché non tutti siamo
così bravi da poter approdare al
Nazionale la prima era economicamente
davvero insostenibile la seconda
probabilmente è arrivata quando ero già
in là con gli anni e non avevo voglia di
iniziare da capo però su una TV
nazionale ci sono finita e vi faccio
vedere quando
la vera TV e ospite il 5 Stelle Peppe
Giorgini consigliere regionale delle
Marche e la politica
la politica
[Musica]
in diretta Scusate se adesso arriveranno
i nostri tecnici purtroppo
[Musica]
Eccoci qua insomma avrei voluto finirci
per altri motivi però almeno spero di
avervi strappato un sorriso non sarò qui
a farvi una lezione su quella che è la
mission del giornalista oggi si parla
Ovviamente sempre del raccontare la
verità con continenza pertinenza
schivando un po' quello che è il
sensazionalismo No oggi se ne parla così
tanto vi parlo un po' del compito del
direttore che è il mio Il direttore non
sta più tanto On the road a ricercare
servizi notizia a parlare con la gente a
fare interviste sinceramente manca molto
spesso è quello che fa un po' da
collante alla redazione quindi in
qualche modo Cerca di evitarsi le
querele cerca di evitare le sanzioni
disciplinari fa sì che la redazione
lavori in armonia però perde un po' il
contatto l'aderenza con l'onda Road
quindi la strada la vita vissuta e le
persone da intervistare in qualche caso
però anch'io da direttore sono scesa tra
virgolette in Campo ecco ad esempio per
il delitto sartier con la mia collega
Abbiamo deciso di impostare diversamente
il nostro notiziario un po' quello che è
l'approfondimento informativo della
nostra emittente perché crediamo che
oggi se non ci siano inchieste se non ci
siano approfondimenti se non si vada al
cuore delle vicende delle notizie della
cronaca purtroppo non si riesca a fare
un buon lavoro e soprattutto l'emittente
locale non si diversifica dai cosiddetti
nuovi media che molto spesso non hanno
la stessa autorevolezza ma sono un
bacino a cui molti di voi con un
semplice Kit sul cellulare riescono ad
attingere notizie E allora che abbiamo
fatto abbiamo ricostruito tutto il
percorso della povera vittima in questo
caso Pietro sartie è un venditore di
pesce che è stato ucciso da due pentiti
nell'alto Maceratese perché era troppo
bravo nel suo mestiere questi due
pentiti volevano la sua fetta di mercato
che era semplicemente quella della
vendita al dettaglio del pesce Pensate
un po' perché è stato ucciso e abbiamo
ricostruito il percorso che Pietro fece
quella mattina fino a una frenata Ecco i
killer gli sballarono una strada lo
fanno frenare e lo freddano con diversi
colpi di pistola davvero un'esecuzione
poi cercano di far scomparire tutto io
con la collega mi recai in loco
ricostruire diverse fasi del delitto e
quella che vedete è la frenata del
furgoncino di Pietro sarchie la
riprendemmo noi qualche giorno dopo il
delitto e finì nel fascicolo
dell'inchiesta perché effettivamente
quell'impronta corrispondeva allo
pneumatico del furgoncino di orecchie e
da lì si parti con le indagini nel corso
della conferenza stampa il procuratore
della procura di Macerata Giovanni
Giorgio ci fece Complimenti e ci
ringraziò perché comunque avevamo dato
in qualche modo il nostro contributo e
secondo me avevamo fatto quello che un
giornalista doveva fare approfondire
Ecco le parole del procuratore Quindi
siete stati molto bravi ci avete
consentito con il vostro filmato e la
vostra presenza e partecipazione Almeno
a me Ecco di ricostruire
quello che è accaduto ecco Quello era il
filmato fra poco ne vedremo un altro E
insomma dicevamo inchieste
approfondimenti ma stare sul territorio
fare in modo di essere presenti sempre
cioè la notizia va vissuta in prima
persona non a distanza non bisogna
farsela raccontare telefonicamente tanto
più una televisione che è immagine deve
essere lì a raccontare con le immagini e
attraverso le testimonianze quello che
sta accadendo a differenza di altri
media il 24 agosto 2016 anche in quel
caso in prima persona mi trovavo ad
Arquata del Tronto prima e poi a Pescara
del Tronto e ogni 24 agosto noi
riproponiamo questa clip con le nostre
immagini e le voci che parlano più di
mille racconti giornalistici
[Musica]
una ragazza di 13 anni Riva che è
rimasta sotto le macerie è una signora
di 40 anni che siamo quasi riusciti a
tirarlo fuori
sì un attimo il tempo di arrivare
Ecco questa era una clip girata con
immagini che noi
girammo appunto in quella mattinata del
24 agosto attorno alle cinque sei di
mattina non era arrivata ancora nessuna
troupe proprio perché era franato un
ponte ad Amatrice e quindi le truppe
nazionali non riuscivano ad arrivare poi
si fermavano tutti ad Amatrice perché
avevano capito che lì c'era il dramma in
termini di vite umane più evidenti più
grosso Noi invece siamo una TV di Marche
Abruzzo ci siamo concentrati sul nostro
territorio su Pescara del Tronto su
Arquata e su tutto quello che stava
accadendo nelle Marche perché questa
clip emozionale perché secondo noi
racconta più di mille parole quello che
è accaduto in quei giorni la sua che
abbiamo vissuto in prima persona
è stato difficile ve lo dico quella
mattina alle 6
buttare Praticamente il microfono sotto
il mento di quelle persone che avete
visto uscivano con le coperte termiche
dalle macerie in quel momento ti domandi
ma io sto facendo il mio lavoro da
giornalista o sono uno sciacallo che non
ha pietà di queste persone che vivono un
momento così drammatico poi ti rendi
conto che senza quelle testimonianze
nessuno avrebbe saputo in diretta o
comunque il registrata quello che stava
succedendo e vai avanti è una scelta che
fa in quel momento ma che negli anni poi
ti domandi Sempre se sia stata giusta o
sbagliata di fatto quel materiale tra
virgolette passerà un po' alla storia
perché racconta di una Pescara del
Tronto raccontano anche le immagini che
purtroppo Avete visto non c'è più la
ricordate adesso è completamente Rasa al
suolo le testimonianze di un dramma però
non arrivano solo attraverso le nostre
parole o le semplici interviste arrivano
anche attraverso le parole che arrivano
dal cuore di queste vi del sisma E noi
continuiamo ad intervistarle perché
reputiamo che il ruolo di una tv locale
sia questo stare sul territorio
Raccontare il territorio raccontare le
persone che lo abitano e per questo ci
siamo inventati ancora oggi va avanti
una rubrica che si chiama storia dal
terremoto che portiamo avanti
Praticamente con cadenza quasi
settimanale queste storie dal terremoto
ci permettono di lasciare i riflettori
accesi proprio su quelle zone una storia
che vi volevo far sentire è quella di
Giacomo eupizi che ha fondato una
cooperativa e che produce vino cerca di
ripartire dallassù dalla sua Arquata
però ancora nei suoi occhi c'è il
ricordo di quella notte allora io mi
trovavo in un paesino qui a Borgo di
Arquata
io ho saputo di Pescara alle 7 di
mattina alle 6:58 Quindi siamo rimasti
dalle 5:30 lì c'era il campo sportivo
siamo rimasti combinati Lì però non
pensavamo che fosse così grande la
tragedia anche se il terremoto era stato
fortissimo
consideri che dopo la seconda scossa con
la seconda scossa abbiamo sentito le
mura ad arquata che cadevano le urla
ricordi che rimarranno per sempre
[Musica]
Ecco gli occhi lucidi di Giacomo Perché
Perché li usiamo non perché vogliamo
fare TV del dolore ma perché servono a
lanciare un messaggio nel corso della
storia che poi avrebbe raccontato ci
avrebbe spiegato quello che è il dramma
che stanno ancora vivendo per dover
ripartire E quindi queste storie Spero
che Tocchino anche il vostro cuore i
battiti del vostro cuore perché è
importante riuscire a lanciare un
messaggio lo facciamo così perché molte
volte è una testimonianza di questo tipo
reputiamo che serva molto di più che
magari le parole di un assessore di un
sindaco o di qualsiasi altra persona
perché l'emotività molto spesso ci aiuta
a lanciare un messaggio in questo caso
il messaggio è che abbiamo ancora
bisogno di aiuto il tempo è tiranno In
conclusione Vi volevo dire che abbiamo
cercato come emittente di non
spettacolarizzare il dolore la
sofferenza ma ci abbiamo cercato di fare
un'informazione che sia più credibile
possibile anche in tempo di pandemia
quando c'era da fare prevenzione quando
c'era da spiegare soprattutto in una
prima fase quanto fosse importante il
distanziamento sociale l'utilizzo delle
mascherine E che cosa davvero si andasse
a rischiare e per questo abbiamo
realizzato diverse interviste con
persone che con il covip purtroppo
avevano avuto a che fare sperando che
insieme alla parola degli esperti a
queste testimonianze si riuscisse in
qualche modo ad arrivare al cuore ai
battiti delle persone alla pancia delle
persone si riuscisse a far arrivare un
messaggio e una di queste testimonianze
simbolo che è stata cliccatissima anche
sul web è quella di Franco cardelli che
è un noto ristoratore di Castellalto che
ha una pizzeria che ha aperto anche a
San Benedetto e che ha avuto il covid e
si è salvato per miracolo vi faccio
ascoltare qualche sua parola
era marzo il 17 marzo
avevo problemi di tosse non saturavo
bene allora sul consiglio del mio
dottore
mi ha chiesto di andare in ospedale e lì
mi hanno subito ricoverato per farla
breve e la notte stessa sono stato
intubato Però ha avuto fiducia e dopo mi
hanno svegliato che era mi hanno detto
oggi ai 24 aprile lì per me sembrava
così fino a quando le cose magari
migliorano Quindi se Dio sono qui perché
sono contento di raccontarla ce l'ho
fatta
Ecco avete sentito il fischio che a
Franco è la testimonianza Palese di chi
ha passato ha sofferto il covid Ecco la
sua testimonianza legata a quella di
esperti medici Per sensibilizzare sul
tema della prevenzione da covid era
fondamentale Ecco la televisione questo
deve fare deve lanciare dei messaggi che
siano importanti attraverso la formula
più corretta possibile Insomma senza mai
rischiare la propria credibilità e
autorevolezza Ecco questo è fondamentale
e in tema di idee visto che parliamo del
Tex Indro Montanelli diceva sempre che
di non aver potuto raccontare narrare
attraverso i suoi articoli le sue idee o
almeno tutte le sue idee ma di non aver
scritto un articolo o un servizio che in
qualche modo non rappresentasse il suo
pensiero e questo è un po' anche il
nostro spirito guida in chiusura volevo
ringraziare Sara e Silvia che sono state
due compagne di università per caso ci
siamo iscritti alla stessa l'università
ma sono rimaste per me due amiche nella
vita che mi hanno dato questa grande
opportunità di essere non solo la
presentatrice del Tex ma anche in questo
caso una speaker e in chiusura vi faccio
salutare da lui dal comprimario su
questo palco che nel corso dell'ultima
ecografia alzato la manina e come la
mamma ha salutato tutti e ha detto basta
è finita Grazie
[Applauso]